(solemn music)
- Okay, greetings everybody.
Welcome to lecture three.
I knew when I was gonna give this lecture
that it would be after
I had gone to Ukraine
and back in-between.
So the nice people who are filming this
asked me not to wear the same
shirt as I wore last week,
both times, which I'm
sure you guys noticed.
I didn't notice.
It was very tactful for you
guys not to mention that.
(class laughs)
'Cause I could've just worn
the same shirt all semester,
and you guys would've been cool.
You wouldn't have said a thing.
I am wearing the same shirt
that I wore on the train,
because the train is 30-
It's like, from here to,
in case you were thinking
about doing this next weekend,
it's a solid 35 hours from
here to the center of Kyiv.
And there's no way to make it shorter.
That's like in the best case.
So I knew when I was
gonna give this lecture
that I was gonna be going
there and back again.
And so I thought I would make
this subject of this lecture,
what I'm calling Geography
and Deep History,
or maybe just Deep Geography for short.
That is, the way that
we think about places
and how the way we think
about places then has to do
with how we apprehend
what happens in the world.
So the subject today is going
to be naming and placing
and how the names and
the places then affect
how we understand events before our eyes.
Which may seem a little
misty and abstract,
but hopefully as I get into the geography
and then a little bit into the war,
it will come clear
how the deep notions that we have of place
tend to suggest, trigger,
push us in certain directions
when we're confronted with events.
So what is the place I was going to?
So in the reading, this
is kind of ambiguous.
So the place that I was going
to, maybe it was Ukraine,
or maybe it was the Ukraine?
What's the difference?
I have already told some of
you what the difference is,
so don't cheat.
But what is the difference
between going to "Ukraine"
and going to "the Ukraine"?
I mean, you probably know
that if you say "the Ukraine",
you'll get disapproving
looks from the Ukrainians.
But beyond that, what's the difference?
Yeah.
- [Student] Saying, going to the Ukraine
implies that Ukraine is a region,
a sub-region of something like
Russia or the Soviet Union.
- Exactly.
So if you say "the Ukraine",
it already, it means,
in Polish you can actually
say "going to the Lithuania",
which you can't say in English,
but that suggests where
this all comes from.
It's important to remember that English
is not the master language for everything.
And that very often, the
way we say things in English
actually comes from somewhere else.
So we say "the Ukraine" because
in Russian and in Polish,
you can say, "na Ukraina".
Yeah, I even have this
on the sheet this time,
you can say "na Ukraina",
which is something like more like "at".
So you're going to someplace
which is not quite defined.
As opposed to "v",
"v Ukraina" or "v Ukraini,"
which means "in Ukraine".
It's a place that's like, if it's a "v",
that means it can be contained.
So it has a border. It's a defined place.
Maybe a state, because a state has borders
and a state is defined.
So if you say "na", you're not
really talking about a state.
And you may be talking about something
which is kind of misty and undefined
and maybe a little bit poetic.
So in your reading, up to now,
like the article from Rudnyts'kyi,
who cannot be accused of being
anything but a Ukrainian,
it was still okay in the
'60s for him to be saying,
or maybe it was required
of him, I'm not sure,
to say "the Ukraine".
And while we're on the subject of-
Okay, so is that clear,
the "v" and the "na"?
So it's very important,
if you're speaking Polish
or Ukrainian or Russian.
And so, the Poles, it's interesting,
the Poles all switched
over in the early '90s.
They switched over.
When I learned to speak Polish,
you were supposed to say,
"na Litvia", but now people say-
that means sort of "at Lithuania",
but now people say "v Litvia",
meaning "in the state of Lithuania".
And "na Ukraina" was how I was
taught to say it in Polish.
But now I would say "v
Ukraina" because it's a state.
And Ukrainians have very
clear ideas about this, too.
So while we're on the subject, though,
you might have noticed
that the capital of Ukraine
is spelled a couple of different ways
in your readings as well.
What's the difference there?
Anybody wanna take a stab at that? Yeah.
- [Student] One is the Ukrainian spelling
and the other is the Russian
spelling and pronunciation.
- Yeah. One is a transliteration. Exactly.
So you guys know what transliteration is?
There are many alphabets,
and when you render from one
alphabet to another alphabet,
that's called transliteration
or transcription, technically.
So in the standard English spelling
of the capital of Ukraine,
for a very long time,
until very, very recently,
in fact, was Kiev, K-I-E-V.
And that was a
transliteration from Russian.
In Ukrainian, it's Kyiv,
hence the English
transliteration, K-Y-I-V.
Which is a little bit awkward,
because there just aren't that many words
that don't involve '90s punk bands,
which have Ys and Is in front of them.
The Y-I is not a normal
combination in English.
And this was an evolution.
So in my early books,
I wrote Kiev, K-I-E-V,
just because I thought,
"This has been standard
in English for so long.
It's not really such a big
difference between Kiev and Kyiv.
People reading English are
just gonna be distracted
by this Y and the I together.
Why should I do it?"
But then at a certain point, I changed.
The last few books, I spelled it
with the Ukrainian transliteration.
And if you want, you can check and see
when the New York Times changes.
Because the New York Times
always does everything right.
(class laughs)
And, (laughs) thank you, that was good.
The New York Times always
does everything right,
but even the New York Times has
to change from time to time,
how they're gonna do certain things.
And so you can check and
see when they changed
from spelling it one way to another way,
'cause that represents a certain
kind of cultural consensus.
And so, these things change.
And the reason why it's
interesting that they change
is that these things that
might seem to be superficial,
like language, are actually very deep,
because they're the things
that you read and you take in,
you don't call them into question.
And then they may form
how you see the world
when you're confronted
with something surprising.
So, the "v" and "na" or the "the":
Is it a region or a country?
Kiev or Kyiv: Is it
Russian or is it Ukrainian?
It's a pretty big-
And what is actually normal in English?
This is really interesting,
because you might think,
let's say, you're, I'm assuming
many of you are native English speakers.
All of you know English, or
you wouldn't be in this class.
Or you're in this class doing
some kind of weird meditation
that involves listening to a
language you don't understand,
which is cool. You'll
probably pass, anyway.
(class laughs)
I'm assuming if you're doing that,
you're taking it pass/fail.
But you might think, "Well in English,
we all have a certain
distance from all this.
There's a certain objectivity,
whatever it is in English
is somehow just neutral."
But it's not.
What it is in English has
effects too, very much so.
And what it is in English
is also subject to change,
as we've seen in both of these examples.
Just in the little span of time
between when your readings start and now,
the basic uses in English
for both the country and
its capital have changed.
And you're presumably, if you have kids,
which I know that none of
you are thinking about now,
because when you signed to go to Yale,
you promised not to get married
and not have kids, I know.
But when you have kids, presumably,
they will think K-Y-I-V is totally normal.
Maybe you already think
it's totally normal.
And they'll think, it
will not occur to them
that it might have been some other way.
But these things change all the time.
Now this notion of deep
geography also has to do,
so I've talked just about
of words and letters.
It also has to do with narratives.
So a story can tell you where you are.
A story can tell you where
you are before you get there.
And this occurred to me during this trip,
because I was talking to a
bunch of American diplomats,
and we were pondering,
I mean, just to put it
very briefly and brutally,
we were pondering why every
American gets everything wrong
about Ukraine all the time.
Like that basic question,
which you can't help dealing,
you can't help asking
with respect to the war,
because even the people
who were supposed to know
what they're talking about
were totally wrong.
It's a luxury for me to
say this because I wasn't,
but in general, everybody
was totally wrong
about everything with respect to the war.
Ukrainians are gonna
lose after three days.
They can't possibly fight back.
They're gonna lose, it's a
stalemate, blah, blah, blah.
Everything that the
consensus has said in the US
has been wrong the whole time.
And you can't kind of say,
"Well, this is just a matter
of lack of military analysis,"
or whatever.
No, there's something
else deeper going on.
And we were sort of trying
to ponder that together.
And I think it has to do
with the deep narrative
that everyone is taught.
Because the deep narrative
that everyone is taught,
all these diplomats were taught it too,
everybody who studied East Europe,
almost everybody, not in this class,
but almost everyone who
studied East European history
in the US has the narrative, which says:
There was Kyiv.
And then, from Kyiv,
somehow there was Moscow,
there was some kind of transfer.
And the thing in Moscow was the same state
as the thing in Kyiv, even though that,
I'm not gonna say "even thoughs",
I'm just gonna try to tell the narrative.
The thing in Moscow somehow
inherited the traditions
of the thing in Kyiv.
And therefore the thing in
Moscow fulfilled itself,
when it actually incorporated
Kyiv in the late 17th century.
That was somehow natural.
That's part of the destiny of this place.
And it's normal that Moscow and Kyiv
will be together forever.
And in some way, it's all
Russia. It's all Russia.
So I didn't do a good
job with that narrative,
because frankly, that's
not what I'm being,
that's not my job here to do a
good job with that narrative.
But that's the basic narrative.
But the point is that everybody
who has ever studied this
has that narrative.
And if you have that narrative,
then it makes you think
that Russia's a real place.
And what is Ukraine?
Because in that narrative,
nothing called Ukraine ever appears.
So there must be something
suspicious about Ukraine.
It must be somehow invented
or somehow marginal
or somehow provincial or
in some way questionable.
Whereas nobody ever questions Russia.
No one ever- I mean, is that wrong?
No one ever questions that
Russia is a real place.
No one ever questioned the Soviet Union
was a real place either.
And then, one day it ceased to exist.
No one ever questions that
Russia is a real place.
There's a non-zero chance
that the Russian Federation,
as we know it, will cease to exist.
In fact, there's a 100%
chance that every place,
I mean, that's, that shouldn't...
Know there's a 100% chance
the Russian Federation
will cease to exist.
All states that have ever
existed have ceased to exist.
There's also a 100% chance
the United States of
America will cease to exist.
Probably not before you
graduate, don't worry.
(class laughs)
Unless you're freshmen, in
which case, eh, I'm not so sure.
(class laughs)
But all states cease to exist.
So any narrative about
how something's gonna be around forever
is obviously going to be wrong.
But my point here is that as I was sitting
with my fellow Americans
and thinking this over,
it kind of seemed clear
that the reason why they,
Americans, people generally,
have trouble imagining
that Russia could lose this war to Ukraine
has something to do with the fact that
Ukraine isn't quite real in
their minds and Russia is real.
And they wouldn't say that directly,
but the narrative which you're
taught when you're younger
is gonna be there for you always.
We live in time in one direction.
Our history education happens
in only one direction.
And the things that get
in first tend to stay.
Now, we don't have to spend a lot of time
challenging that narrative.
That's not really the point here.
The point though, is
that, just if you believe,
if this is your deep geography,
that this was always Russia,
and then if it wasn't Russia,
that was some kind of divergence.
If that's the way you see it,
then naturally your brain,
when you get to thinking about the war,
of course, you're gonna
think Russia's gonna win.
Because this was always Russia,
and Ukraine is some kind of exception.
Yeah, do you have a question?
Oh, sorry. Okay.
And, "always" is a very powerful word,
but it's also a very comfortable word.
We really like "always".
We really like for things
to have a kind of durability, continuity.
We like for there to be
something in the world
where we know its shape, and
we know its shape is permanent.
And it is a little disturbing
when it turns out that
none of these things
that we think are permanent actually are.
That's a little disturbing.
And so Russia has made it into the level,
I think it's fair to say,
you can correct me, I mean,
I realize you guys are young,
you're from a different
century and all that,
but Russia has made it into the realm
of the kind of calmly permanent.
It's up there with, I don't
know what, Star Trek, hydrogen,
it's like things that
have always been there.
Whereas Ukraine has not.
Whether that's fair or
not, it's probably unfair.
But I think that's the case.
And we just don't like it
when something which is "always"
is called into question.
So, "always" is very comforting.
And of course, Russia
itself, that word "Russia",
in a deep geography,
it's not clear where the
borders of that Russia are.
I mean during this war, there's
been a lot of really, quite,
let's call it ambitious
Russian propaganda.
There are now placate,
what do we call placate?
- [Student] Posters.
- No, wrong.
Billboards. (snaps fingers)
There are now billboards.
I mean, that's true, but like billboards.
You get points for speed
though, both of you.
And it wasn't wrong, I was
just thinking of a different-
Like billboards in Russia,
which say Russia has no borders.
Which is one way to think about it.
No borders at all.
But my point is that,
when we think of Russia,
we could be thinking of the Soviet Union,
we could be thinking
of the Russian Empire,
we could be thinking of
a lot of different things
with very different borders.
And since the borders
change, it's a big place,
we're not surprised to learn
that a lot of things are Russia.
A lot of things turn out to be Russia.
So you get my point.
There is a reason why
basically everybody except
the military historians
kept saying Ukraine is gonna lose.
And one of the puzzles of
this class, if you want,
is to think about why that is.
Why would everyone be wrong?
And the suggestion that I'm making
is that this thing that
I'm calling deep geography
has something to do with it,
with the words, the
spellings, the narratives
that indicate to us what is
real and what is not real,
before we get into the empirical world.
Because as I suggested
before, if you read,
there aren't that many
military historians left,
but if you read them
and their boring threads about
logistics and all this stuff,
they don't know anything
about Russia or Ukraine,
but they know where the rivers are,
and they know where the
bridges are and so on.
And they've done a much, much better job
than the people who are supposed
to be Russia specialists.
Why is that?
Why is it that not knowing
anything about Russia
seems to be an advantage
in predicting who's gonna win this war?
And so you see what I'm trying to suggest,
that if what you know about Russia
has this kind of metaphysical underlay,
which is actually, then,
pushing the empirical evidence around,
that's going to be a problem for you.
So basically what I've done so far-
Yeah, go for it.
- [Student] Is there something
distinctive about America
that makes our narrative wrong?
Like, is there a different European,
because of the proximity to the area,
that the predictor-
- Well, in Poland,
there is, yeah. (laughs)
In Poland, there is.
All of this sort of stuff
that I'm calling anti-colonial and so on,
like the Poles and the Ukrainians
have been making these
arguments for a long time.
But as soon as you get west of Poland, no,
it's the basic, it's the
same story dominates.
That Kievan Rus' somehow becomes Moscow,
somehow all the same place.
When Moscow takes over Ukraine
in the 17th century or
in the 18th century,
that's somehow a fulfillment,
even though Kyiv and Moscow
have been apart for 500 years,
even though Kyiv has never
been ruled by Moscow before,
somehow that's a natural
fulfillment of history.
500 years is a long time, by the way.
But that basic story is
dominant in Germany and France,
and in England, it's not just us.
It's a story, I'll get to
why it's an ironic story.
So, what I've been doing so far,
is I've been making a case
for how important literary
history actually is.
Like how important culture actually is,
and how important
cultural critique can be,
like being aware of the
narratives and the words and so on
can help you to understand the politics,
or being aware of the culture
can help you understand
political judgements.
What I want to move on to now,
is just a word about how
you then address this.
How you begin to talk about it.
And one way that we'll be
talking about it in this course
is the very broad approach
of colonial history.
Where one of the first things that you do,
if you're doing colonial history,
is you question the neutral
claims of knowledge.
You question, whether the
things that have been laid down
might in some way have been
laid down with an imperial spin,
which has to then be queried.
So if you're doing colonial history,
you're taking for granted that there's,
that the libraries have been
organized the wrong way.
Or at least they've
been, I won't say wrong,
but they've been organized a certain way,
that even the language has
been organized a certain way,
so that you don't see some things
that you might otherwise see.
Now, these are arguments that many of you
might be more familiar with
in an American context.
Where you would say that
in American history,
one has to be very careful,
because American history has
been laid down in such a way
that you might not see, for example,
the history of enslaved people.
That's probably a very familiar argument.
But that's a generic
anti-colonial argument
that can be applied in
lots of other settings
around the world, including
in Russia and in Ukraine.
So in colonial history,
you're asking yourself
to question the apparent
neutrality of knowledge,
including the instruments of knowledge:
languages, spellings, maps,
library organizations.
And you're also asking yourself,
"Can people change halfway?"
So if these concepts have
been laid down into us
and we've accepted them as neutral,
are we actually capable of
catching ourselves halfway?
Which is a very important
history question.
Because if it's not possible,
then we might as well give up on history,
because we all have a lot
of legends laid into us,
imperial and otherwise.
And getting to history is a
matter of being able to say,
"Huh, well, maybe some of
the things I'm committed to
maybe might not be correct."
So I want one of you to figure out
how many lecture classes
there are on Ukraine,
on Ukrainian history right now in the US.
'Cause I'm gonna say one,
and I want you guys to prove
that there's another lecture
class going on on Ukraine
in the United States right now.
I'm gonna guess that,
despite the fact that it's
in the news and so on,
I'm gonna guess there's only one.
And that's sort of, that
would be weird, wouldn't it?
I mean, would you go that far with me?
I'm gonna say one, maybe two.
Like full-on lecture classes
that are just about Ukraine.
Not classes where
somebody mentions Ukraine,
or a Ukrainian poem is assigned,
but a full-on class about Ukraine.
In our country with 300 million people,
in our fantastic higher
educational system,
I'm gonna go with one,
and I'm gonna be surprised
if it's more than two.
So somebody figure that out by next class.
Because it's an example
of what I'm talking about
with the institutions.
Because no one would disagree
now with the proposition
that something important
is going on in Ukraine.
If something important
is going on in Ukraine,
that means something important
could go on in Ukraine.
If something important
could go on in Ukraine,
why are we so woefully
unprepared for that?
There has to be an
answer to that question.
It has to go somewhere,
it has to go somewhere deep.
So if you're doing colonial history,
you question the neutrality of knowledge,
you look for ways,
and one of your methods
is you look for ways
for the colonized to talk back.
Not that they're right, by the way.
It's not about how one is
right and the other is wrong.
That would be oh, too simple, right?
But rather, when you hear
how the colonized talk back,
then it shakes you a little
bit and gets you thinking
about how you might do things another way.
So I was in Kyiv for several days
and I stayed up late watching,
'cause I didn't anything else to do,
actually, I had a lot of
other stuff to do, (laughs)
but I stayed up late
watching Ukrainian television
because I find it just really
ethnographically interesting
to soak in the news in a country
where something's going on.
And they have ways of talking back.
Later in the semester,
you're assigned an article
about "ruscism," that I wrote.
Ruscism, to make it very simple,
is a kind of merger of the
words "Russian" and "fascism".
And ruscism, or with the
personal noun, Ruscisti,
has become a pretty
standard way of referring
to Russians who are invading Ukraine.
So standard in the sense
that the newscasters use it.
They don't say "Russia".
They rarely say "Russians".
They almost never say "Russia".
They occasionally say
"the Russian Federation".
But usually they talk about the Ruscisti,
and they talk about ruscism.
And when they refer the country,
they're calling it "Moscovia".
Why would you call it Moscovia?
Besides the fact that sounds sort of cool.
Go for it.
- [Student] You're breaking the link
between Russia and Kievan Rus'.
- Yes. You're taking the Rus'.
So, Russia is called Rus',
which is a name that Russia took in 1721
when the Russian-
when the Russian Empire was founded.
If you call it Moscovia,
you're taking away the
historical reference to Rus'
and you're also kind of naming it
as a smaller country than it is.
And you're suggesting that its boundaries
might have a certain
flexibility. (chuckles)
You're also kind of suggesting
that when you say Moscovia.
The other phrase they use a lot
as a euphemism for Russia
is "aggressor state".
They say aggressor state.
Which is like neutral.
"It's the aggressor state."
But it's also not neutral
because you're suggesting that
that state might always be
an aggressor, and so on.
So the next thing that
I want to talk about
in this notion of
geography and deep geography
and deep history is
I want us to think a little bit about
this late 20th century,
early 21st century notion,
that of globalization,
and the idea that globalization has made
all this kind of careful
work that we've done
in the first few lectures
of this class irrelevant.
Because what globalization does-
this is the argument.
What globalization has done is that,
to use Thomas Friedman's phrase,
it's flattened the world.
It's kind of made everything
the same everywhere.
I mean, his example,
one of his examples, was
airport lounges,
which frankly, I don't
think is a great example,
not least because
they're really different.
I mean, the ones in America
are terrible, for example.
Okay.
But I give it as a joke
in a different way,
because of course,
airport lounges is not a
representative experience.
So the fact that airport
lounges might be similar,
or McDonald's might be similar,
doesn't really take you very far.
But what I'm really going for
here is the overall argument
that since the end of
communism, something like that,
since the rise of global trade,
the second globalization,
things are basically interchangeable.
Places are basically becoming
more like other places.
And people are also
becoming interchangeable.
Because there are only so
many ideas in the world
and we share them all
instantly through the Internet,
goes the idea,
therefore we're interchangeable.
Maximus and I are interchangeable.
Zhenya and Maximus are interchangeable.
So it doesn't matter what
TF you have, actually.
(students chuckle)
We're all basically interchangeable
because we're all sharing
ideas all the time.
And there are only so many ideas,
and we're sharing them instantaneously.
So maybe you don't have
the idea I have right now,
but you can have it instantaneously.
So this is the notion.
So in this utopian view,
space doesn't really matter.
Traveling distances doesn't really matter.
'Cause we're all really kind
of all in the same place
in the same time.
Now the objections to
this are pretty clear.
One of them is, does
information really travel?
In the world where we are,
well over 90% of the supporters
of Viktor Orbán and Hungary
believe that Ukraine is
at fault for this war.
And why do they think that?
They think it because that
is their information space.
What Russians and Ukrainians
think about this war
is obviously very different.
And it's not just because
they're Russians and Ukrainians,
it's because they're in
different information spaces.
What you and your cousin Harry
may think about Donald Trump
might be very different.
And that might not just be because
you and your cousin Harry
have other differences.
It might be because you are
in different media spaces.
One could argue that
what's happened, actually,
is that information space
has created more differences
or it's created even firmer
boundaries than existed before,
because the Internet, arguably,
actually travels less well
than a newspaper does.
If I can print the same
newspaper all over the world,
as used to be the case,
then I may be actually
doing better than I'm doing
if I'm the Washington Post
and I can't get my stuff
out in China today.
So, information maybe doesn't
really travel, and it may-
And can we really go everywhere.
I mean, this is obviously on my mind,
'cause it took me 35 hours
to get back from Kyiv.
But there is a certain
cost in going places.
And when you take your
body certain places,
it does have an effect
on how you see things.
There's a difference
between being in a place
and seeing it on a screen.
If you go somewhere
and it involves passports
and changing the gauge of a railway,
or it involves going through checkpoints,
that is different from
just clicking on a picture,
to another picture, to another picture.
It changes the person.
By the way, one of the things
I found really interesting
on the checkpoints,
and it has to do with this
overall question of language
and where you are and how
language suggests where you are,
the Ukrainian soldiers
generally still speak Russian.
That's not really a big secret.
But at the checkpoints,
if you're at a checkpoint,
the way they greet you
is they hit you with a really
flowery, friendly Ukrainian.
And as long as you can hit them back
with a really flowery, friendly Ukrainian,
you're basically through the checkpoint.
Because there just
aren't that many Russians
who can do that.
So you make sure you show your document,
but the language itself
is the first checkpoint,
which is kind of interesting.
But where I want to really
go with this is that,
in historical terms, it
really does seem to matter
how far people get at certain times.
There really do seem to be
historical turning points
where non-interchangeable
people get, or don't get,
to very special places, and
that it seems to matter.
A big classic example that
we'll get to in about a week,
in our part of the world, is
the Mongol invasion of Europe.
The Mongol invasion of Europe.
Well, when did the Mongols reach Paris?
I see, yes?
- [Student] They haven't yet.
- Yeah, good! Good answer.
I like that. I like the "yet",
I like the way you're
holding the future open
for good things.
(class laughs)
That's awesome. That's really good.
Yeah, so in the late 1230s, early 1240s,
the Mongols aren't defeated by anybody.
The Batu Khan is not defeated by anybody.
We'll talk about this.
They have the stirrups,
they have the encirclement
maneuvers, they have the calls.
They're not defeated by anybody in Europe.
They destroy every army,
European army, they touch.
And that includes Kyiv,
but it doesn't include France.
Not because they couldn't have done it,
but because at a certain point,
the Batu Khan has to go
back for a succession issue.
'Cause the main Khan has died.
But if the Batu Khan gets to Paris,
I mean, arguably no Renaissance,
no Age of Exploration.
Probably some other part of the world
carries out the Age of
Exploration, not the Europeans.
And it's a very, very,
very different world.
And that's just a matter
of one person dying.
If one person had died a year later,
we're probably looking at an
extremely different world.
Not to say that the moment we're in
is quite comparable to that.
But it does strike me as
being significant that,
and of course you can't
help but think about this
when you're standing
in the middle of Kyiv,
but it seems quite significant
that Russian soldiers
do or don't get to Kyiv
in February of 2022.
And it's really close. It's really close.
The Russians land in
the Hostomel Airfield,
and their plan is to land there,
drop the paratroopers, drop
the special forces, go in,
gather up the elite, kidnap
them, probably exterminate them.
And that's part of the
plan to take over the city.
And they get to Hostomel,
which is only about 35
kilometers, 20 miles,
from the center of Kyiv.
They get that far on the
first day of the war.
They get that far, but
the Ukrainians stop them.
There's a terrible battle around Hostomel
and it goes on, but the
Ukrainians stop them.
Bucha, which you probably heard of
because of the atrocities,
And, I saw Bucha very briefly too.
It was also very, that was
also kind of interesting
because the air raid
sirens went off in Bucha,
and I was with the Ukrainian general
and he was like, "Well, we
can always go to the basement
of the church, if anything
actually happens."
Bucha is basically a bedroom community.
It's like 28 kilometers from Kyiv.
It's a suburb.
Irpin, where so many
buildings are destroyed,
it's like a beautiful parked,
it's a really nice place.
You might wanna, if you were
like going up in the world
and you wanna have a nice
place and drive, commute,
the American dream.
If you wanted to do that,
Irpin would be a wonderful place to go.
Now it's all shot up,
and there's a huge pile of burned cars,
and there building after
building was destroyed
by Russian tanks as they were retreating.
That's like 20 kilometers from Kyiv.
And the same is true
going the other direction
across the Dnieper towards Chernihiv.
The Russians got very,
very, very close to Kyiv.
But they didn't get to Kyiv.
They didn't get that little difference,
those last 15 miles of physical geography
would seem to make a huge difference.
And the way people react to the war
also has a great deal to do with
how they understand the
geography around them.
So for example,
time after time after time,
people who lived in Kyiv or other cities
would say, when the war started,
"i should go to the villages,
I should go to the suburbs."
That's a natural thought.
Like, "They're gonna get to Kyiv,
I should go to my dacha, I
should go to my grandmother's,
I should go to my second house."
But it was the villages actually
that took the punishment,
time and time again.
People from Kyiv went to Bucha and Irpin,
because they thought Bucha and Irpin
would be safer than Kyiv, which
turned out not to be true.
A friend of mine who lives
close to the Dnieper,
the Dnieper runs through Kyiv.
And so, a friend of mine assumed
that the Russians would
get as far as the river,
and the Ukrainians would
then blow the bridges,
and then you only have
one direction to flee.
So in moments like this, you're
thinking in terms of space.
I wanted to go someplace besides Kyiv
and Bucha and Irpin and Hostomel.
I wanted to get outside of Kyiv Oblast.
And so I went with a friend to Chernihiv,
the Chernihiv Oblast,
which is just basically due
north, a little bit east.
Chernihiv is a fascinating city.
We're gonna return to it.
It might have been on one of your maps.
The reason it was on one of your maps
is that it's an old city.
It's 500 years or so older than Moscow.
It's been there for a very
long time. It's ancient.
And it is an ancient
center also of scholarship,
of theology and of scholarship.
Along with Kyiv, it was one
of the two great centers
of religious, and intellectual
in general, disputation
in what's now Ukraine.
And one reason why I
have Chernihiv in mind
is that this whole story
about the Kyiv and the Moscow
and how it's all one place,
that was actually invented
by a guy in Chernihiv.
It was invented by one person.
Like now, we all believe it.
It has this incredible effect on-
And the reason he invented it
had everything to do with geography.
Oh, I forgot to put his
name on the sheet. Okay.
(chalk tapping)
So in the war, in the Cossack
wars of the 17th century,
which don't worry, we'll get to,
in the Cossack wars of the 17th century,
at the end of it, there's
basically a stalemate
between Poland, the
Polish-Lithuanian Commonwealth,
and Moscow.
And the stalemate is codified
at the Treaty of Andrusovo in 1667.
And according to that treaty,
the territory on the east of the Dnieper
was going to be Russia,
and west of the Dnieper
was going to be Poland.
It was a little unclear
what that meant for Kyiv,
because Kyiv was on both sides,
but eventually Kyiv
ended up being part of,
being under control of, Moscow.
And that meant Chernihiv was as well.
So Kyiv and Chernihiv, which
are these major centers
of European scholarship and thought,
are now suddenly under
the control of Moscow,
which has no centers of
scholarship and thought.
And no, that's just a statement of fact.
I mean, there aren't any universities,
there aren't any academies
in Moscow at that time.
So Lazar Baranovych was
a very intelligent guy,
one of the great theologians of his time,
and used to enjoying a certain
amount of personal influence,
it should be said.
And when Chernihiv and
Kyiv fall under Moscow,
he makes a play.
And see if you could think of a play
which is as good as this play.
He says,
to the fellow Orthodox
clergy in Moscow, he says,
"You know what? We're
actually all one country.
And the history of your
country, that one in Moscow,
it actually begins in Kyiv."
And this was news to the people in Moscow.
This had not occurred to them.
This was not their story
of themselves at the time.
But Baranovych said,
"Your history actually starts with Kyiv."
And of course, why does he say that?
Because that makes Kyiv really important.
Because, so suddenly Ukraine
and Kyiv and Chernihiv
are not just places that
got conquered by Moscow.
It turns out they're the beginning
of the history of Moscow.
And that dignifies him,
and it dignifies his
collegium, his school,
it dignifies Chernihiv, it dignifies Kyiv.
That seems like a pretty good play.
And it worked. For a while, it worked.
But you can then imagine
what happens next.
What happens next is that eventually,
the Russian clerics say, take
over the story on their own.
And they say, "Yes, okay, that's true."
But, after a couple generations,
they pick up all the tricks
that the Ukrainians use to argue.
They learn the languages, too.
They start reading
the Western religious
literature themselves.
They learn about theology and disputation.
And so they take the argument
and they make it their own.
And then by the 18th century,
it becomes a secular argument,
no longer a religious argument,
but a secular argument.
When the Russian Empire is formed to 1721,
it's called the Russian
Empire for this reason.
And then when Russia invents
a secular history of itself
in the 19th century, it's this story.
But this story happened
because of this guy,
who, if he drowned under his horse,
as people tended to do at the time.
If something had happened to him
on the way to writing that letter,
maybe that story would never have arisen.
And then maybe we would
all analyze this war
a little bit better than we did.
And so, again, I'm just
trying to make the point that
where a certain person is
at a certain time and place
may matter, actually, a lot.
Like you couldn't actually
trade Lazar Baranovych off
for anybody else. He
wasn't interchangeable.
And those circumstances,
that Chernihiv fell under
Russia at that particular time,
were very specific.
So Chernihiv itself was
bombed in early March.
I was told by the locals, I
haven't checked this yet myself,
but the guy who was actually
doing the bombing runs
was himself born in Chernihiv,
which raises the question
of how you can believe
different stories about the
place where you're from.
When I was in the rubble, I was in-
There was one really terrible bombing run
which destroyed, or partially destroyed,
four major apartment
buildings in one neighborhood.
And when I was there talking to people,
I was struck by a few things.
Like how, I mean, just like
this place for young people,
like there was a kid there
who was collecting books.
He had a book collection.
And he found an iPhone in the rubble.
Like he had all these
books and he had an iPhone,
and as he walked out, he said
to me, "I found an iPhone!"
Like, this is his childhood.
But also one thing that struck me is that
in these apartment buildings,
people don't necessarily know each other
or know who they are.
But then after the bombing,
people did know who one another were,
because they had to help
each other with things.
And then it turns out when
a building is destroyed,
that it has a history.
One of the reasons you know that is
that the same kind of bombing
will destroy different kinds
of buildings in different ways.
So Soviet-era kommunalka,
or Soviet-era buildings
that were put together from modules,
are very vulnerable to
bombing, it turns out,
whereas post-1990s buildings
are generally less so.
And you can literally see that
worked out before your eyes.
Or another thing, in
this complex of buildings
that was destroyed, one
of them, it turns out,
like this is something you
would never have to know,
but it turns out that
one of them was built for
survivors of the nuclear
disaster in Chernobyl.
And so they all came down
and they got this building
as a way of moving away
from where they were.
But that history would never have come out
without this other event.
When I went to the suburbs of Chernihiv,
I mean, the villages around,
I talked to a woman who
had five Russian soldiers
in her house, in her basement.
And I said, "Okay,
they're Russian soldiers,
but where were they actually from?"
Were they Russian, or were they some-
And she's, "Oh, they were
from Bashkiria and Tatarstan,"
and I think maybe one of
them was Russian from Russia,
he was from Siberia.
And they had a geography.
They had a notion that Ukraine was Russia.
But it's a funny kind of geography
because they're from so far away,
they're from thousands of
miles away, in some cases.
And there she is, and they're
all speaking Russian together.
And she's a native Russian speaker.
She was talking to me in Russian.
And they're telling her what Russia is
and that she's in Russia.
And there's something
very strange about that,
but that's their deep geography,
and there's something about it
which seems to really matter.
I'm gonna leave you with the last example,
which I'm sure you probably
already thought of,
which is Kyiv itself.
So the way we think about cities
often has to do with
particular things that happen
in those cities or in those neighborhoods.
Like Wannsee might not
mean anything to you,
but Wannsee is where
a famous plan was made
for the extermination of the
remaining Jews of Europe.
It's a part of Berlin.
And so you, you cannot,
once you know that,
you can't hear Wannsee
and not think about that.
Or Vichy.
So Vichy in France is,
I mean, there's nice soda
water and everything,
but it's a spa town,
but it's also where the
collaborationist government
had its capital during
the Second World War.
And so Vichy means that.
It's very hard to take
that away from Vichy.
I would suggest that there's going to be
a little something around Kyiv like that,
but in a positive sense,
because Zelensky stayed.
If Zelensky had left,
many things, I think,
would be different, in
the world and in our minds
and in this class, probably.
But he stayed, and I think that makes Kyiv
mean something different than
it would've otherwise been.
In other words, I'm trying to suggest that
this deep geography, although it's real,
is also fungible, it's changeable.
It can be altered by human action.
I'm thinking in particular
about the night,
a couple of nights into the war,
where he made the selfie
video, where he said,
"President tooth."
"I'm here."
And then he goes on,
"My advisors are here.
We're all here. We're all right here."
And he was countering Russian propaganda,
which had said he had
fled. That's part of it.
But also, he was saying,
"I'm here, I'm going to
stay. I'm reassuring people."
And this is just my last
example of the point that
maybe places and people
aren't so interchangeable.
That it matters a great deal
that when he said, "I am here,"
the buildings behind him were Kyiv,
and not Lvov and not Warsaw.
That everyone in Kyiv,
when he said, "I am here,"
could recognize where he was in Kyiv.
And that "I'm here" was also the counter
to a different kind of deep geography.
Because at the moment when he said that,
there still were bombs falling in Kyiv
which were meant for him.
And there were still groups of assassins
moving towards Kyiv, or actually
inside the city of Kyiv,
who were meant to kill him.
And they were operating under
a different deep geography,
deep geography which
goes something like this.
And I'm not, I don't have to invent this
because it's what Putin
said in in 2021, 2022,
that Russia and Ukraine
have always been one place,
and the people who say that
Ukraine is a different place,
they are somehow exotic.
They somehow come from the outside.
They're Hapsburgs, they're Poles,
they're Europeans, they're Americans.
And therefore anyone who
says that there's a Ukraine,
there's something flawed
about that person.
They don't belong there.
They simply need to be removed.
And we'll remove them lexically,
by calling them Nazis
or whatever it takes.
But we're also going
remove them physically.
Because if we remove them physically,
then the rest of the Ukrainian
people will go along with us,
and the war will be over.
That is a kind of deep geography.
And that deep geography
animated the attempt
to take Kyiv and to kill this person.
So I had a lot of time
to think about that,
because if you're visiting the President,
it takes a long time to
get there, obviously.
Because like, they lead you
here and they lead you there,
and then you're never
gonna find your way out.
They lead you here, it's
all dark and confusing,
and there are lots of checkpoints,
and there're lots of barriers and things.
And so it gets you to think,
how important is it actually
that this person is right here,
as opposed to another person right here,
or this person being somewhere else?
So, the deep geography is important.
That was the point of this.
But also the deep
geography can be changed.
The deep geography can
be changed by action
and by experience and by renaming.
And I was thinking about that,
I think about that as well.
I was there during this last,
this Kharkiv counteroffensive,
when the Ukrainians took
back almost all of Kharkiv.
And of course, that
means that Kharkiv Oblast
now means something different
than it did a few days ago.
And for the men and women
who were involved in that offensive,
it's gonna mean something
different to them as well.
And that the fact that
so many Ukrainians
have had to move during
this war, for bad reasons,
4 million deported to Russia,
well over 10 million crossed a
Western border and come back,
people inside the country,
well over half the population has moved
in one way or another.
And that moving is associated
with the changing of meanings.
And sometimes it's associated
with a change in meanings
in a positive sense.
This is just the very last thought.
But I was really struck,
I mean, I'm not trying to
make a happy story of this,
because of course it's not a happy story,
but I was really struck by how,
when people talked about
all of this movement,
whether it was the President himself,
or whether it was some of
the soldiers I talked to,
or whether it was some
of the people in villages
that I talked to, when they
talked about all this movement,
they had interpretations of it,
that like this in some
way shows who we are.
The fact that we went away and came back,
The fact that we were
able, or have already-
a lot of people have already
rebuilt their houses,
the fact that we rebuilt,
the fact that we got back to Kharkiv,
the fact that Zelensky stayed,
that these things say something
about us, about who we are.
We can be pushed, we can be pulled,
but then where we choose to be in the end,
says something about us.
That we choose to fight this war,
that we choose to help the
people fighting this war,
that we choose to make it through somehow,
says something about us.
And so in that sense,
like this thing that
people are talking about
as the formation of a nation,
I think, is not quite right.
The nation was already there.
But how people think about their nation,
and particularly what they
think it means to be free,
and what it's worth sacrificing about,
you can also connect that to space.
In fact, I guess my point would be,
you almost have to connect it to space.
It's hard to imagine people
having a story about themselves
which involves risk and values,
which doesn't also in
some way involve space.
And that's where I'm
gonna leave it. Thank you.
(gentle chimes)